[Music]
um it's virginia five years and thanks
very much to all of you who are joining
us whether that's early morning in the
uk or whether you are joining us from
india or anywhere else in the world the
discussion today is going to be looking
at innovation and the future of
capitalism now from adam smith to john
maynard keynes economists have argued
for free trade and the innovative power
of capitalism to improve living
standards and prosperity many
governments support that rhetoric but
it's not always the reality almost all
countries still impose widespread
tariffs in order to protect their
citizens should we give up the rhetoric
or change the reality is free trade and
innovation not the capital capitalist
panacea but rather the cause of
increased inequality
do we need to limit change to protect
people or would global free trade enable
developing countries
and economies to thrive create higher
living standards for everyone and
unleash the power of innovation for
everyone to benefit there's quite a lot
to get through but certainly a very
provocative topic and we have three
great speakers who are going to go
through that with us so let me introduce
who we have we'll start with praveen
krishna distinguished professor of
international economics and business at
johns hopkins university he served as a
consultant to the world bank and the imf
a prominent supporter of uh indian prime
minister modi's liberalization of india
although has recently cited concerns
about prime minister modi's government
potentially backsliding into
protectionism the second uh introduction
is michael howard uh leader of the
conservative party in the early 2000s
who also held prestigious cabinet
positions in governments including
secretary of state for employment and in
the environment as well and of course as
british home secretary and last but not
least prem shankar ja
a renowned indian economist journalist
and writer who's worked at the united
nations and consulting on the undp um he
was also information advisor to uh
indian prime minister vp singh um and
was a former editor of and the contr
contributor to the hindu newspaper but
also has written for many many indian
publications so there we go a really
distinguished panel to discuss things
with us um let's start by
opening with a pitch from all our
speakers which looks at the central
question when it comes to trade
which goal is more important praveen
krishna
is it greater prosperity
or is it reducing inequality
um on the issue of international trade
uh let me say the following
international trade first of all has
been a key driver of growth and poverty
reduction parts of your question about
inequality i want to be careful in my
comments to distinguish between poverty
and poverty reduction which is which are
some kind of one end of the income
distribution that
essentially what happens at the bottom
of the income distribution and
rather than the difference as the rich
getting richer while the poor may also
be getting richer and then what's the
difference between the two these are
these are distinct concepts and i think
they need to be treated uh separately
but first as far as just international
trade and
being over the reduction
let's keep in mind the example of china
a stunning example of a country which
has been able to draw hundreds of
millions of its citizens out of poverty
with a growth model that was largely
based on technological change and
international and much the same is true
in india where we also have seen large
reductions in poverty in the two decades
after india began its market reform so
poverty in india maybe about 50 percent
of the 1970s early 1980s is down to
about 20 it's a very significant
reduction
in the context of international trade
once again in market reforms
and indeed no developing country one
could argue is achieved kind of high in
sustained levels of growth without
participating substantially in
international trade and by and large
with the growth that's come with trade
and kind of micro reforms and so forth
have been impressive reductions in
poverty and indeed improvements in all
of the human development indicators that
we would be concerned with
now it is
definitely can put some jobs under
threat and even if it is the case that
most economies believe that
technological advances really contribute
far more to job losses and dislocations
um
to low-skilled jobs then right but
nevertheless one should keep in mind
whether it's technological change or
trade for instance when the automobile
was first invented it was bad news for
blacksmiths and horse breeders and so
forth the electric light was a was
problematic for capital makers
would really bring millions of jobs in
the automobile sector in the lighting
sectors so some level of dislocation
some inequalities may be to be expected
with trade and innovation um and if
these turn out to be significant and
severe then
it's of government
uh suitable policies adjustment
assistance reskilling workers maybe even
the introduction of policies in a
gradual manner uh to support uh support
such okay the last thing i'd say very
quickly should inequality get out of
hand which get very substantially richer
as a process of openness and
globalization surely there are other
mechanisms like just income taxes rather
than protection that we could rely upon
as a government to limit that thank you
very much for that let's um go to prem
next so three minute pitch um what's
your take on this
my pitch is quite simple i may even take
less than three minutes
um i think that the important thing is
we need to distinguish between a free
market
and
free trade
free markets are inside a country
free trade is freedom of markets between
countries um
basically
what competition does a market economy
does
of course as you know it promotes
efficiency
and the this best
but this
this competitive market is itself a
sort of a passing thing
because the competition itself wipes out
the weather
and the numbers left become smaller and
smaller and eventually if you look at
all the the the mature capitalist
economies of today they are oligopolies
there is just no free market
that's the honest truth
the fact is the free market today is a
myth
what is free
however is
that
in this
in in the in the domestic markets you
have the capacity the state has the
capacity and the workers have the
capacity to in fact make sure that the
benefits from the increased productivity
and efficiency of competition do get
passed on to the to the to the workers
and you should britain is an excellent
example i don't i don't need to go any
further but the whole whole of
continental europe and to considerable
extent the us are all in this category
free trade is between countries and that
today
is a complete free for all
and that does not necessarily lead to
greater prosperity in in in in the
poorer countries yes we have
one last point
yes it is true that's the east asia
um and southeast asia benefited from
free trade but they benefited even more
from the transfer of technology
to these countries in order to enable
them to be able to
trade in the goods that the west needed
okay thank you very much um and last but
not least michael howard what's your
pitch
i think we're really
trying to build a conflict where it
doesn't exist there's no necessarily
conflict between prosperity and equality
um as has been pointed out as praveen
pointed out
free trade uh and capitalism
have in the last quarter of a century
led to the greatest reduction in poverty
our planet has ever seen uh and we don't
celebrate it enough uh and that couldn't
have happened without capitalism and it
couldn't have happened without a a
considerable degree of free trade
because the countries
in which uh the greatest reduction in
poverty has taken place have been able
to
improve the condition of their people
through free trade um but i do also
agree with prem
that the internal market um it does have
a tendency towards oligopoly and that
countries should
uh impose much more vigorous competition
rules um to curb the the oligopoly
oligopolistic tendency um
competition is the lifeblood of
capitalism competition is the key to
capitalism and if competition erodes
then capitalism doesn't work properly
and governments have a really important
role to play
in fostering competition
and
curbing
monopoly power um just over a hundred
years ago an american government
was able to take very radical measures
to deal with the lack of competition in
some of its key industries oil and
railways in particular
and i think
we need much more vigorous competition
policy in today's world to deal with
some of these monopolies
okay thank you very much um so let's
start with that first theme to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas